you are pretty favorable pretty
optimistic on consumer stocks overall
right yeah so consumer was the biggest
underweight we had the first six six and
a half months of the year uh and we've
been adding you know pretty aggressively
there over the last couple of months and
I think it sets up as a pretty
interesting contan trade right now so
we're telling people uh go along the
consumer discretionary stocks short the
banks right now for the fourth quarter
even though both are cyclicals you know
they have you're right they have
commonality of exposure to to
fundamentals actually the net income
were correlated by 08 retail and Banks
yeah the reason is housing uh um
employment rates those things feature
into both but I like consumer right here
because comps are going to be easy from
a year ago you know you order Apparel in
kind of April May for Christmas they
order way too much in 2013 they learned
their lesson and Order less this year so
sale pricing won't be as aggressive
inventory won't be as aggressive you've
talked about oil being at the bottom end
of the range that helps the consumer uh
I think expectations in sentiment are
far lower if I look at maybe the banks
you know they uh the stocks have been
really well the last kind of 6 weeks on
a relative basis yet the 10e yield
didn't really back up to relase the Nim
pressure housing the second derivative
slowing so I I kind of think as a
contrarian trade I'd rather own some of
these uh into the fourth quarter into
the Black Friday kind of noise that you
guys will be talking about in few weeks
yeah isn't that mindboggling it's
already uh I'm I'm waiting for Christmas
decorations couple pumpkins first and
then we get to the Christmas yeah right
so um you just you look at retail over
the past um couple of years last year
there was a problem with UPS uh getting
the shipping uh there was also the bad
weather um that lowered sales the year
before that the consumer didn't have
money is there a bugaboo in retail this
year you know I don't know I mean we
have a macro indicator that shows that
some of the uh stuff is really starting
to inflect at the at the low end I do
think this oil thing is crucial that you
mentioned I I think it just cost people
less at the pump and that makes them
feel a little bit more flush into the
into the holiday season yeah you've also
been looking at deal making it's it's a
good way for companies to plug the
earnings Gap and the strong US dollar
kind of changes the tone for for us
companies looking to make acquisitions
doesn't it it could a little bit look I
think you're going to get the second
wave is more conventional m&a where big
us companies buy small us companies
right I think the key is that the
acquirers the stocks actually have been
going up yes that's a distinction you
know when I when when I started in this
business nobody ever said anything other
than the deal will be a creative in year
three because they knew it wasn't in one
and two and they just thought three it'd
be fine right so I think right now these
thingses are creative much faster if not
immediately and so the acquirers are
interested and I think the other thing
that's important to note is big
companies that are doing Buybacks in the
last year have actually been
underperforming big companies that
aren't so it's almost like the Market's
giving a message saying hey you guys you
guys you guys can't really grow fast
enough offset that yeah in other words
go go use your cash strategically don't
don't just buy back stock and engine or
hire we need growth we need growth right
so I I I think the signs are there that
you could get some more m&a picking up
to be honest with you how come we
haven't seen as much intensity um among
small and midcap stocks when it comes to
m&a because I think the first wave here
was about the tax Arbitrage and and
inversion and you've seen a lot of that
in healthcare and other areas is that
over well the government's trying to
obviously do some stuff to make that a
little less uh and some of those deals
are going forward in spite of it yeah
because they they make sense you know
even above and beyond that in many cases
but but I think you'll see with cost of
capital law with confidence slowly
improving that that happens and look the
other thing that could do is capital
spending and we know High cap exit sales
companies underperform low cap ex sales
companies so I I think it does make
sense that this is a natural evolution
of where we head in the next couple
years yeah right I remember two years
ago when you had been a bear and you
switched to a bull people are like it's
been a three-year run you said it's
going a lot farther than you were we
could be could be could be 10 years
we'll see